In an October 2025 announcement, Wizards of the
Coast floated the idea of a change to the way
hybrid mana is treated in the deckbuilding rules
of EDH. This caused quite a lot of discourse,
which I laid out some thoughts on in a previous
video that was uncontroversial and universally
beloved by the EDH community. However, that
October 2025 announcement also featured some other
things, one of which was proposing the banning
of Rhystic Study, the powerful blue draw engine.
That particular card has been in a perpetual
state of low-level controversy for some years now,
being both the third most widely played blue
card but also the second most hated blue card
according to salt polls conducted by EDHREC. And I
won’t bury the lead here: I don’t like this card,
and I absolutely think it should be banned.
However, my reasons for thinking that are
different from those of a lot of other people, and
I actually think that this card and the discourse
around it is a fascinating window into some of
the grittier instincts of EDH players, the ones
we don’t like to think about or talk about.
At the end of the day, Rhystic Study’s power
level is certainly quite high, but the destructive
social dynamics it creates are the more pernicious
element of the card, and these two factors combine
to make it a card that absolutely warrants a ban.
To start with, though, we need to understand
what it is we’re talking about: why is it that
a card should be banned in EDH? After all,
it’s a casual format—a lot of the usual rules
of tournament frequency and meta dominance don’t
really apply. We can look at the current banlist,
as well as other actions taken against specific
cards, to start to paint a picture. I choose to
begin in a familiar place—Yuriko, the Tiger’s
Shadow is a card that spent seven months on the
gamechangers list last year. It was eventually
delisted under the reasoning that a rule 0 tool
like the changechanger list is far less
necessary for policing commander cards,
which are visible at the outset of a game, but
Yuriko still works nicely as an example of a
card that sometimes feels problematic in EDH. As
I laid out a couple months ago, Yuriko feeling
problematic comes down to two things. For one,
she is efficient and powerful, being very cheap
to play and providing a ton of utility through
her mixture of damage and card draw. Secondly,
her play pattern is frustrating—since her
commander ninjutsu ability dodges commander tax,
it is quite hard to keep her off the board, and
it often feels like the Yuriko player effectively
gets to cheat the normal rules of the format.
So, these are typically the two things required
to make a card truly problematic—a high power
level, and a play pattern that is frustrating.
We can see this echoed in some cards on the
banlist—Hullbreacher and Leovold are efficiently
costed creatures, and they also easily combine
with wheels to blast away opposing hands. Primeval
Titan and 15 mana Emrakul are both high-quality
bombs that would see wide play if legal,
and their abilities also let their controller
rapidly snowball and end up playing a lot more
Magic than opponents. We can even see this in
the fast mana bans of 2024—Mana Crypt and Jeweled
Lotus are obviously very powerful, and the fact
that they allow such explosive turn 1 plays can
be frustrating and disempowering for opponents in
a way that some other powerful cards might not be.
Not everything currently on the ban list or the
gamechanger list perfectly fits this framework,
but this power level + play pattern pairing
is still a decently reliable template. For
something to be worth banning in EDH in the year
of our lord 2026, it needs to be frustrating in a
way that creates bad experiences for people, and
it also needs to be powerful enough to see wide
play and make that bad experience commonplace,
so as to actually warrant a ban rather than
just being an occasional annoyance. As we will see
shortly, Rhystic Study checks both of these boxes.
To start with, let’s talk power level. On an
objective level, Rhystic Study’s power level
is very high, and this is evident in the fact
that it’s one of the best cards in cEDH. Surely
these expert gamers know how to play around this
bad boy, right? But no, Rhystic Study is quite
powerful even if all of your opponents are being
tactical about paying the 1. If somebody wants to
cast a piece of interaction that spends all their
mana, they’re not going to be paying the 1. If
somebody has a pivotal play on their turn and no
extra mana to pay, the correct choice is to play
the card and let the Rhystic Study player draw,
not to skip your own turn. There are all sorts of
cases in which it is absolutely the correct choice
not to pay the 1, and that makes Rhystic Study
a pretty great card draw engine on base. Now, as
you move down in power level, decks will get a bit
less lean, have spare mana a bit more often, and
cast fewer overall spells each turn. If I’m being
generous, I think this is where a lot of people
get the idea that Rhystic Study isn’t really
problematic after all. It does scale with power
level to some extent, especially when we consider
that the maximum card draw in a game with 3 spells
per player per turn cycle is significantly more
than in a game with 1-2 spells per player per turn
cycle. However, this still misses some things.
For one, at bracket 3, cards are going to cost
more mana typically. Whereas an engine in cEDH
might be 2 or 3 mana, it’s pretty common to see
engines in bracket three that cost 4 or 5 mana,
and if you only have 4 or 5 mana to work with, one
of these cards is going to be much more possible
to pay the tax on than the other. This is true for
engines, and it also certainly applies to removal.
A lot of people will make the argument that
Rhystic Study can be answered by simply
removing it, but this misses two key things.
For one, you can say this about basically any
problematic permanent, but there are still
very good reasons to ban permanents. Prophet
of Kruphix is a piddly little creature that can
be removed far more easily than Rhystic Study,
but there are still very good reasons for it to
stay banned. “Just remove it” is a strategy you
can employ, just as making somebody the archenemy
is a strategy you can employ, but neither of these
things are arguments to keep a card legal on
the scale of a format-wide banlist. Secondly,
any removal spells cast on Rhystic Study are
themselves Rhystic-taxed. Best case scenario
it costs an opponent a mana, but if the removal
isn’t super mana-cheap there’s a good chance the
Rhystic Studying player will get a card as well,
and that’s all assuming that the blue player isn’t
prepared to play counterspells in defense of
their copy of the most powerful draw engine in
the format. In the land of reality, counterspells
frequently are present, and any multi-spell fight
over whether a Rhystic Study stays on board will
often itself draw the Studying player a lot of
cards. There are also people who downplay the
severity of a Rhystic Study sticking around on
board. A lot of pro-Rhystic folks will casually
present Rhystic Study as a one-sided Sphere of
Resistance. “Like c’mon bro, if you just pay the 1
it’s only 3 mana to make all opposing spells cost
one more, a tax tool more powerful than any other
that has ever existed. It’s not that bad.” This is
just patently absurd. A three mana one-sided
Sphere of Resistance is obviously good, and
there’s a reason Grand Arbiter Augustin IV is such
a salty card even as a 4 mana multicolor card.
I think all of what I just said is pretty
reasonable, but also I worry that my engaging
with the one-sided Sphere of Resistance talk
legitimizes it in a way that it absolutely does
not deserve. Rhystic Study would be an extremely
powerful Magic card if it was a one-sided Sphere
of Resistance, but it is not that, and this
is where this video is going to really start
to diverge from most critiques of the card I’ve
seen. To start with, let’s just establish that
people will inevitably end up giving the studying
player cards for any number of reasons. I laid
out a couple reasons earlier that frequently apply
to cEDH, and these reasons arguably strengthen at
lower levels. “Just pay the one” can be a sensible
strategy when a deck features high quality plays
at multiple different mana values, like if you’re
forced to play a three mana ramp spell instead of
a 4 mana amplifier, that really might not be a
huge hit to your gameplan. On the other hand,
if your deck has a wider spread of mana values and
card effects, paying the one could keep you away
from a critical play that you really need on a
particular turn. This effect is further amplified
when there are power level differences present.
If one player has a deck that is less tuned,
whose ramp isn’t as well calibrated, and whose
plays are less mana efficient, that player is
going to get hit harder by the Rhystic Study
tax. Ditto for somebody who gets unlucky or
keeps a subpar hand—anyone who misses land drops
or fumbles their setup turns a bit is going to be
much less able to spare mana for Rhystic Study,
and being pressured to do so on a critical turn
might, in one fell swoop, destroy any chance they
had of catching back up. I say pressure because
Rhystic-Study-esque effects frequently come with
a dose of social pressure not to feed the studying
player too many resources, and this fact can feel
reasonable on the surface, but this pressure to
pay will be experienced very differently by
different players. The players most harmed by
needing to pay an extra 1 for their spells will
be, on average, the less experienced players
piloting the less powerful decks and getting less
lucky, and whether or not these players are pushed
into ruining their own gameplan may come down
to how they react to the social forces at play.
With this in mind, the “just pay the 1 lol” crowd
starts to appear in a somewhat different light.
In a weird way, arguments in defense of Rhystic
Study often end up very similar to conservative
economic arguments in favor of the status quo.
Hear me out on this one. Let’s imagine somebody
trying to introduce a policy in a society with a
lot of economic inequality. John Allocation says
“We should implement my tax credit plan, as it
will give all the people of this great nation more
of a fighting chance at succeeding in this economy
and joining the middle class.” This is an economic
argument, and whether it’s likely to do what John
says it will do can be determined by digging into
the details, running some models, and whatever
else economists do. Now, let’s imagine John’s
political rival has something to say about that.
Jeff Business says “This economy already gives
citizens a fighting chance at joining the middle
class, just look at all the hardworking people who
have already succeeded.” In a society with a lot
of inequality, this is not an economic argument.
This is a moral argument. The people currently
below the middle class indisputably exist,
and rather than asking why that is or what can
be done to help them, Jeff Business is instead
choosing to turn them into an out-group to be
ignored. His implied message is that there is
something wrong with the people who are currently
poor, that they are less deserving, that they have
been given opportunities and squandered them,
and that they have earned their shake in life.
It wouldn’t matter if John Allocation’s tax
credit had been highly successful at helping
people elsewhere in the world, here it would
be disrupting a divine order that has put this
pathetic outgroup in their correct place. It is an
argument in favor of human suffering based on the
idea that those people have earned that suffering,
and no longer deserve our consideration.
When somebody says “Rhystic Study isn’t that good,
people just need to pay the 1,” they are making
a very similar argument, if a less consequential
one. Not saying they’re identical, nor that these
are patterns of thought held by all Rhystic Study
defenders or all conservatives for that matter,
but there’s a strong resemblance. What I mean by
that is this: if telling everybody to just pay the
1 was actually a successful strategy for making
Rhystic Study a fair and enjoyable Magic card,
we wouldn’t be having this conversation. The fact
that it’s not a solution, that it’s an unhelpful
thing to say, is already proven by the observable
facts that surround us, namely that Rhystic Study
is a very powerful card at all levels of EDH.
Every day, thousands of Magic players don’t
pay the 1, and there are a variety of different
reasons for that. As I suggested earlier, some
of them are playing a weak deck, or having a weak
game with their deck, and playing a couple cards
into the Rhystic Study is the only way to keep
up. Or maybe they’re newer to the game and don’t
have a firm grasp on the power level of an engine
like Rhystic Study, as suggested by the Trinket
Mage in his video on this subject. Maybe they’re
overwhelmed by the current state of a game, and
choose to go about their turns ignoring Rhystic
Study for that reason, only paying when doing
so is a convenient afterthought. Maybe somebody
sees other players not paying the 1 for any of the
previous reasons, and decides that it’s time for
them to stop paying as well. This is the reality
of Rhystic Study, not the quippy hypothetical
of a smug power-gamer. You can make some sort
of argument toward educating people about playing
against the card, just as an economic conservative
might meekly gesture toward the importance of
teaching people to budget, but all of the four
situations I described earlier will continue
to exist no matter how high a rooftop you yell
“just pay the 1” from. “Rhystic Study is fine,
people just need to pay the 1” is not an argument
about game balance, it is a moral argument
about the people currently not paying the 1.
So, if saying “just pay the 1” isn’t a helpful
solution to the problem of Rhystic Study,
why do people say it? Well, one answer to this
is pretty simple—taking this stance solidifies
hierarchies in the EDH community in a way that
some people find emotionally satisfying. It
forges an in-group to be a part of—genius gamers
who understand Rhystic Study—and an out-group to
be scorned—everybody else. On a basic level,
this is kinda inevitable—tribalism is a folly
pretty inherent to being human, and the fact
that it shows up in a card game whose formats
are traditionally competitive isn’t much of
a surprise. Where things start to get hairy
is when these sorts of social forces worm their
way into the basic operation of a Commander game,
and this is precisely what Rhystic Study
encourages. Players not paying, a thing that
happens frequently for a wide variety of reasons,
can become treated as a crime punishable in-game
and out-of-game. Frustrations grow, resentments
smolder, a game ends up feeling unsatisfying
for one reason or another. One player’s attempt
to have any shot at their own gameplan working
suddenly gets seen as them handing the game to
another player out of their own foolishness,
and they are often derided as such. And
you know what? Sometimes those deriders
are right. Many a Rhystic-Studying player has
been brought to a victory through the power of
opponents feeding them too many cards. But the
line here is blurry. The difference between a
player handing another the win and a player just
trying to play the game they showed up to play,
just trying not to fall too far behind in tempo to
have any shot—it can be pretty ambiguous. However,
acknowledging that ambiguity, acknowledging
that Rhystic Study frequently puts opponents
in a lose-lose scenario where even the
“correct” choice isn’t all that correct… well,
it makes it too obvious just how powerful
the card is. This is precisely why a lot
of Rhystic Study defenders frame the issue
in such black and white terms—if they spoke
to the reality of the card, it’d be clear
why it’s such an outlier in the EDH format.
So, this is my ultimate issue with the card. It
applies to the most basic of game actions—casting
a spell—and turns the game into a maze of social
pressure. From the perspective of somebody playing
against it in a decent position, you can watch as
your opponents all but hand the Rhystic Studying
player a win, and from the perspective of somebody
struggling in that game, you might be presented
with a choice between attracting the ire of your
non-studying opponents and not really getting to
meaningfully play the game. I’ve heard some people
describe it as a political tool, but really it’s
the opposite of most political tools—instead of
encouraging players to collaborate and make deals,
it divides opponents and gets them to foster
resentments amongst each other. A natural
counterargument that you might be getting ready to
type right now is that this can be a fun dynamic
for a card to create, and I’d get where you’re
coming from. Prisoner’s Dilemma is a decently
popular damage spell for a reason—sowing discord
amongst your opponents can be a pretty good time,
and I can’t say there isn’t something a little
delightful about a blood feud being declared
by a player who just took 12. However, you might
remember that Rhystic Study’s social dynamics are
only part of my case for why it should be banned,
with that other part being its power level.
A disorder-creating card at a very high
power level is quite a different story
from one at a lower power. The stakes are
quite high due to the card’s extremely high
power level, and as a result this card sows
resentments, forges in-groups and out-groups,
and intensifies the information density of the
EDH format at a rate of no other card. It also
shouldn’t go unmentioned that the power level
of Rhystic Study leads to it being played quite
frequently even with its gamechanger status,
in addition to having massive implications for
any game it exists in. This power level plus
disorder interaction also manifests especially
brutally for Rhystic Study because it lacks
the intentionality of an actual political card.
The playerbase at large isn’t running this card
because they have a blast with its play patterns,
they play it because it draws them a metric
shitload of cards, and the negative play
experiences sowed by the card are an incidental
side effect. If you remember my Malfegor video,
this is very similar to the reason I dislike
the play pattern of Tergrid decks—the
oppressive tools Tergrid encourages end up
being impassive engine-fodder rather than
tactically deployed instruments meant to handle
the actual situations a player finds themself in,
and this ends up turning the destruction of
opposing gameplans into a frivolous side effect.
Play patterns like this alienate players from the
effects of what they’re playing, replacing the
tangibility of process and intent with something
simpler and bleaker: the means to a powerful end.
As with “just pay the 1 lol”, appealing to the
supposed fascinating political implications of
Rhystic Study is usually just a smokescreen to
conceal the true, more basic, motivations at play.
So, in conclusion, yes, Rhystic Study should be
banned. There’s a solid argument that Smothering
Tithe should join it, as another card that
rapidly generates resources off of opponents
taking basic game actions, but I won’t delve more
into that here. What I do want to discuss is the
other camp of Rhystic Study defenders, basically
just the people saying “This card shouldn’t be
banned because it’s a popular and iconic part
of the format.” I unfortunately can’t really
attack the topmost level of this argument.
If within your prefrontal cortex lives the
unshakeable axiom that popular cards should
stay unbanned, there’s not a whole lot I can
say to change your mind on Rhystic Study. What
I can say is I find the underlying assumption,
that popularity and iconic-ness should
influence bannability, to be a little strange.
Firstly, Rhystic Study is iconic in large part
due to how unpleasant many people find it. “Do
you pay the 1” is an annoying thing to hear dozens
of times, obviously. Regarding its popularity,
I find this a bit odd as well, since a
card needs to be some level of popular,
to actually affect a lot of EDH games,
to be worth banning in the first place.
You could make a card called Smoogle’s Snotgun
that’s the most annoying thing to ever exist,
but it wouldn’t be worth banning if only 12 people
end up playing it. Things get even weirder when
we dig into the implications of the popularity
argument—one explanation for why Rhystic Study
is so popular is that it’s a very powerful card
that wasn’t banned by the RC at any point in
the first couple decades of the format. This is
interesting when we consider that another card,
Primeval Titan, was banned 15 months after
it was printed, and if it hadn’t been banned
it would likely be an even more popular and even
more iconic card than Rhystic Study. So, what do
we make of that? In that alternate reality would
it be wrong to ban prime time now? Are all ban
decisions effectively being left up to whatever
the RC wanted to do a decade or two ago, back when
the format was largely a charming and slow-paced
sideshow to other Magic events? It’s just a
very strange way to justify the decisions we’re
making in 2026. All this to say, the popularity
or iconicness of a card should not be our primary
concerns when it comes to the EDH banlist. These
are understandable motives for somebody
who produces Magic: the Gathering content,
who is intimately tied in with the tropes and the
mythos and the paratext that surrounds the game,
but those things are not the EDH format. EDH games
are the EDH format, and we should be concerned
with how a card impacts real EDH games that
millions of people play. Does it have a positive
impact, to improve the experience of people
playing this game, or does it do the opposite?
What is the extent of that impact, how widespread?
These are the actual questions worth asking about
Rhystic Study, and I hope I’ve done an adequate
job giving my answer to them in this video.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to
Archidekt for supporting the channel.
Archidekt is my deckbuilding website of choice,
and one thing I like about it is how smoothly it
integrates EDHREC’s Salt Scores into its design,
letting you easily see both individual card salt
scores and the aggregate salt score of
a deck. A link to my decks is down in
the description. Also supporting the channel
is Dragonshield—you can get yourself durable
sleeves in a fabulously wide range of colors
at my affiliate link down in the description,
and you’ll be helping out the channel in
the process. Finally, a big shout out to
my supporters on Patreon and YouTube, who
give me the freedom to make 20 minute video
essays about why I hate a specific card with
my whole being. If you join you’ll get to vote
on what card I say should be banned in my
next video! Okay, that was a joke. Unless?